for sure i got a question uh
some of the footage that i saw i'm not
sure if it was on if it aired anywhere
but the the one of you grabbing the lion
by the tail that was on wow boys that
was on wild
what's the story behind that why why
grab a line by the tail what
it's like a you know it's a
like a manhood thing like went
here here's the thing
i think for for manny to be able to tell
this story we have to reveal a secret
it's not even a secret about wild boys
but um
while with jackass we're very very
honest we had integrity we never tried
to deceive the audience that was jackass
but with wild boys we took liberties to
pretend that we were in africa when
actually we were filming in california
and it wasn't because we we wanted to to
lie to the audience you know in fact
when we went to go film the pilot for
for wild boys in south africa we brought
that two-man zebra suit and we wanted to
go on safari and have a lion there and
we quickly found out that a lion in the
wild on safari in africa you don't get
in a [ __ ] zebra suit and [ __ ] try
and play around with that thing now
so there are a lot of situations like
that and so every time that we filmed
interacting with a lion
like every time we were always
pretending that we were in africa but in
fact we were in california at a place
called hollywood animals
and so
the lion that manny grabbed by the tail
i mean you could say
it was a a tame lion but there's really
no such thing as taming a lion you know
you look at siegfried and roy that
tigers messed that dude up
um but but in any case it wasn't that
didn't happen in africa
no no it happened but the messiah used
to pull
grab a line by the tail on the lion hunt
and the guy that did that he's the one
that would get all the all the women
would come after him he was like the the
cool guys so it was a cool thing to do
you know you know copying another
culture like a messiah in africa my side
line hunters and grabbing the line by
the tail was that the first and only
time you did that
yes
also for the record it's still a cool
thing to do
to grab any lion by the tail
you know you grab a uh domesticated zoo
line whatever his life will turn around
and bite you in half yeah he's reloaded
fully clawed and the people there said
you're on your own
yeah it's called stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and if you go on amazon
and type in stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on amazon and buy
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude